Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, Chat.
Wir machen heute nix.
Ich bin gerade heimgekommen
von meiner Runde.
Also ich bin
Man muss sich das eigentlich mal genau überlegen
Guck dir mal, das ist eigentlich richtig heftig, oder?
Ich arbeite schon
Teilzeit und ich hab heute nur
Ich war heute nur auf der Arbeit
Bis 14.15 Uhr
Also, 14.15 Uhr
Dann
Bin ich heimgefahren
Mit dem Zug, bin ich heimgelaufen
Größere Runde
Hab ich was getrunken daheim
Bin ich 5,5 Kilometer
Rennen gewesen und jetzt bin ich daheim und jetzt
ist 18 Uhr. Ich hab noch
nix gegessen, das steht hier neben mir.
Ich bin aufgestanden, bin ich
um
irgendwie kurz nach 7 oder so.
Muss man überlegen. Und ich arbeite schon
Teilzeit.
Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, wie war das eigentlich, wenn man
wirklich
8 Stunden am Tag
5 Tage die Woche, das ist
da kannst du doch gar nicht.
Ich meine, ich kann jetzt schon nichts mehr machen.
Pillen nicht vergessen.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, Schätke.
Mache ich, ja.
Ich kann das schon nicht.
Ich kann schon nichts mehr irgendwie großartig machen,
neben arbeiten.
Wie machen das wirklich Leute, die 5x8 arbeiten?
Keine Ahnung, wie das möglich ist.
Und dann müssen sie sich von unserem Bundeskanzler erzählen lassen,
dass sie doch zu viel krank sind.
Du hörst dich alt an.
Jetzt auf einmal.
Wie kommt's?
Sonst sagen die Leute immer, ich höre mich an, ich höre mich zu viel jünger an.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Oder nur heute?
Ach, das Thema.
Wieso?
Das Thema ist doch bei der jungen Generation...
Also, ich bin außerdem alt, ja.
Das Thema ist, wollte ich gerade sagen, das Thema ist bei der jungen Generation doch besonders angesagt.
Die haben aus meiner Sicht berechtigtermaßen keinen Bock auf fünf Tage die Woche, acht Stunden am Tag.
Das wird bei mir gar nicht funktionieren.
Wenn ich, wenn ich, also ich mach das ja auch öfters bis 15.30 Uhr.
Aber dann bin ich erst.
dann bin ich erst
17 Uhr
oder so daheim. Und wenn ich da noch
eine Runde rennen will oder so, das 18 ist
18, das ist
scheiße, da kannst du nichts machen.
Warum kein
Homeoffice?
Ich hatte die letzten eineinhalb Wochen
Homeoffice. Heute war ich in Frankfurt,
weil wir hatten Besuch
vom Abteilungsleiter.
und da hat unser Chef gesagt, guckt doch mal, dass ihr alle da seid.
Ja, und das will man ihm dann ja auch erfüllen.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn du morgens mit Bauchschmerzen schon hingehst
und auch so es kaum noch schaffst, das restliche Leben auf die Reihe zu kriegen,
das Erste, was ich mal machen würde, ist, das meinem Doktor erzählen.
Ich würde da erstmal mit deinem Arzt drüber reden, dass du die Probleme hast.
Also sag dem morgen nicht, ich bin erkältet, schreiben sie mich bitte krank,
sondern sag dem wirklich, was Sache ist.
Also wenn es ein gescheiter Arzt ist, wenn es so einer ist, wie ich früher hatte, wo du eigentlich nur hingehst, dass er dich krank schreibt, der halt überhaupt nichts taugt, das wo du nur hingehst wegen einer Erkältung oder so, dann nicht, dann woanders.
Ja, aber wenn du denkst, okay, der Arzt taugt was, dann sag dem das auch.
Sag dem, dass du da psychisch zu viele Probleme hast und sowas auf der Arbeit.
Das ist viel verbreiteter, als man so denkt.
Der kann dich dann nämlich beispielsweise auch kurzfristig mal irgendwo hinschicken, wo du dann direkt Hilfe kriegst.
Also, ja.
Ja, also ich würde tatsächlich mit dem reden. Es gibt auch, also man muss natürlich gucken, was das für einen Schweregrad hat, deswegen ist es auch ganz gut, wenn du mit dem redest. Es gibt ja auch so Ambulanzen, wo du hingehen kannst für psychische Probleme und da ist das eines der häufigsten Sachen, dass die Leute sagen, sie kriegen ihr Leben nicht mehr auf die Reihe wegen Angst, Panikzustände auf die Arbeit zu gehen und kein Antrieb mehr und sonst was in der Richtung.
dann kriegst du da auch meistens relativ schnell so was ambulanz angeht termin und eventuell geben
sie auch noch ein paar tabletten und sowas am besten ist kann ich aus der eigenen erfahrung
sagen am besten ist so psychische sachen möglichst nicht lange warten sondern möglichst schnell
machen weil je länger dein gehirn sich zeit hat das zu lernen
diese nennen wir es mal ungünstige verhaltensmuster ja je länger dein
gehirn zeit hat es zu lernen umso umso mehr schleift schleift sich das ein und
du brauchst dann also kriegst du schon wieder weg aber du brauchst dann einfach
länger bis es wieder weg geht ja also paar monate ist dass das schon heftig
dass das hat ja auch gewissen leidens druck dahinter ja also ich kann mir
wirklich empfehlen morgen bei dem doktor nicht zu sagen hier ich habe eine
erkältung oder so sondern wirklich sagen hier du kannst wegen psychischer
belastung nicht auf die arbeit gehen und hat auch mal gucken ob es bei dir in der
nähe so eine ambulanz gibt für psychiatrie für psychische probleme und
Da hast du zumindest schon mal Ansprechpartner.
Glaub mir, es hilft unglaublich, wenn du überhaupt schon mal einen Ansprechpartner hast und drüber geredet hast.
Ich würde nach Möglichkeit nicht gucken.
Ja, ich würde nicht gucken, dass...
Weil, wie gesagt, umso länger dein Gehirn Zeit hat, sich an so eine Scheiße zu gewöhnen,
umso schwieriger und länger dauert es dann auch.
Also, es geht alles, ja.
Aber brauchst du dann auch wieder mindestens nochmal die Zeit, dich wieder zu entwöhnen.
Ja, das ist schwierig. Also bei so psychischen Sachen ist wirklich wichtig oder sinnvoll, so schnell wie möglich was zu machen.
Auch, und das passiert ja oftmals nicht, weil viele Leute erstmal gar nicht realisieren, dass es das Problem gibt.
Deswegen hast du ja schon mal einen Riesenschritt gemacht, dass du das überhaupt erkannt hast, ja.
Viele Leute realisieren das nicht, viele Leute wollen dann auch beispielsweise nicht das irgendwo erzählen und sowas.
ja, wie gesagt, ich spreche aus Erfahrung
was psychische Probleme angeht
ähm, ich hätte auch früher was machen sollen
ja, deswegen
bei mir geht es langsam aufwärts
man merkt es ja, bei mir ist das
viel mehr Pausen jetzt dazwischen
mit so Problemen und es ist gar nicht
es ist auch nicht mehr so schlimm
und es ist halt auch schneller wieder weg
aber ich habe viel zu lange gebraucht
bis ich richtig mal was
gemacht habe
so
Da wollte ich jetzt immer was zu sagen
Wie lange machst du Mittagspause?
Von gar nicht, also gar nicht ist bei mir
Ich gehe unten beim Bäcker vorbei
Hol mir drei Brötchen und futter die vom Computer
Das ist gar nicht
Ähm, bis zu
So 40 Minuten
Kantine, in Ruhe futtern
Ja
Machst du aber zwischendurch Pause?
Klar, ich schwätze immer mal ein bisschen mit Leuten oder sowas.
Äh, Tommy, was meinst du?
Meinst du so Sachen wie, man muss sich auch körperlich ein bisschen betätigen und sowas?
Ja, das stimmt auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ja, ja, also bewegen ist auch sehr wichtig.
Ja, also ich habe jetzt kein, wie heißt das?
Promodore oder so?
Da gibt es doch diese Tomatenwecker.
Pomodoro oder irgendwie sowas.
Also sowas mache ich nicht, wo die Leute dann quasi sagen,
15 Minuten arbeiten, 10 Minuten Pause und sowas.
Das mache ich nicht.
Aber ich schwätze über Teams mal irgendwie zwischendurch mit ein auf der Arbeit.
Oder wir schreiben mal ein bisschen Blödsinn im Chat oder irgendwie sowas.
also ich mache zwischendurch immer mal ein bisschen pause unregelmäßig wenn ich in
frankfurt bin gehen wir dann mal runter ins café und holen mal jeder holt eine
was ich nicht mal kaffee ich hole mir eine flasche wasser oder sowas
Oh, Max, hab ich gar nicht gesehen
Ja, du kriegst übrigens
Das bessere Nass
Du kriegst
Ich schick das neue doch nicht zurück
Das mit den zwei Performance-Cores
Das kriegst du
Sorry, ich hab sie nicht gesehen
Zeig mal, was hast du geschrieben
Äh, das Wupplaus abläuft, habe ich gesehen
Äh, ich habe es nicht gecheckt
Ja, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt habe ich es gesehen
Gibt es eigentlich das Emote, muss ich mal kurz gucken
Omega-Keg
Irgendwie hatte ich gerade
Das Wort Omega-Keg im Kopf
Aber die Emotes sind dumm.
Wobei, das hier ist gar nicht schlecht.
Connect with Twitch.
Sekunde.
Wir fügen jetzt Omega Kek hinzu.
Wunderbar.
Kurz reloaden, gucken ob es das jetzt gecheckt hat.
Omega-Keg
Ja, hat gecheckt, okay, gut
Ne, es geht nicht um das
N5 Luft
Ich bin nicht lange da
Ich bin nur bis 1930 da
Bevor ich mich hab sidetracken lassen
Am Anfang, ich wollte eigentlich ja sagen
Ähm
Ich bin jetzt gerade quasi heimgekommen
und direkt ans Rechner gesetzt habe.
Ich mache jetzt einfach mal Stream an.
Sonst dauert es wieder so lange.
Sonst ist ja immer nur Wochenende.
Nur Wochenendstream ist auch kacke.
So, ich mache mal kurz hier meine
die
Kiste an.
Soll zwei Wochen regnen.
Na toll.
E-eh, End of Function Zero? Ich hab noch nie Dungeons & Dragons Real Life gespielt.
Ich spiel es aber öfters online.
Gibt's ja zig Seiten mittlerweile.
Hoffentlich hab ich mich nicht wieder vertippt.
Ne, hab ich anscheinend nicht. Okay, exzellent.
So, da sind wir.
Zack.
Oh, wobbly Windows.
Beste Leute, wobbly Windows.
Wobbel, wobbel.
Ne, Pro.
Das Pro ist das.
Warte mal, ich zeig's dir.
Es gibt
Ugreen 4800 Pro.
Das da.
Das ist quasi
das gleiche wie das Plus,
Nur, dass es eine bessere CPU hat.
Das Plus hat 4 Efficiency Cores, 1 Performance Core.
Und das hier hat, glaube ich, 2 Performance Cores.
Genau, 6 Kerne, 8 Threads.
Und das andere hatte 5 Kerne, 6 Threads.
Oder? Ach, whatever, keine Ahnung.
Was nimmt das Ding im Eile?
weiß ich nicht ich habe das noch nicht ausgepackt dass das pro also max
bevor ich dir das schicken kann das müssen wir uns in meinem stream vorher
zusammen angucken dass alle was von haben
ja aber chillfreak das braucht das braucht glaube ich ziemlich viel eitel
strom also ich tippe darauf dass das auch irgendwas um 16 17 watt eitel
verbraucht so was in dem dreh tipp ich jetzt einfach mal drauf so irgendwas wir
können ja mal kurz gucken gibt es hier so eine power consumption ob das
irgendwie mal getestet hat
hdd spinning das glaube ich nicht das glaube ich nicht 12 bis 15 watt mit hdd
Spinning, das glaube ich nicht. Das braucht auf jeden Fall
mehr. Das braucht das Idle mit
HCC down gespinnt.
Ja, die AI erzählt irgendeinen Mist.
Aber 12 bis
18 Watt kommt schon hin.
Ja, 14 bis 16 Bios Optimization.
Ja, das würde ich auch sagen.
So in dem Dreh liegt das.
Bin gerade dabei zu testen, ob ich Casio S als Main OS nutzen kann, aber es gibt leider
keinen Treiber für meine Hercules Stream 200 XL.
Ist das ein Audio Interface?
Ja, ich habe auch ein bisschen Bedenken.
Ich wollte ja auch mein Audio-Interface anschließen an die Linux-Kiste hier, ne?
Aber ich glaube, da gibt es auch keine Treiber für.
Ich hatte mal geguckt, also Moto selbst bietet nur Windows-Treiber an und ich glaube Mac.
Aber vielleicht ist bei Linux was drin, aber ich habe eher das Gegenteil gefunden, dass es nicht richtig geht.
Mit den Platten im Standby 30 Watt Eidel.
Das ist halt, wenn man es mal genau nimmt, ganz schön viel.
Also, es ist jetzt nicht so viel, dass man es sich nicht leisten kann.
Aber es ist insgesamt doch irgendwie ein bisschen viel für das, dass eigentlich die Hardware da drin viel, viel niedriger sein müsste.
Doch, doch, in der Regel schon.
manche Distributionen patchen noch ein bisschen was dabei
oder haben extra
Module, aber in der Regel
wenn Treiber im
Kernel drin ist, dann ist es eigentlich
distributionsunabhängig
einziger Unterschied ist, wenn es noch sehr neu ist
dann hast du bei manchen Distributionen
das Problem, dass beispielsweise Debian Stable
oder sowas den Treiber nicht hat
zum Beispiel hier bei meiner
Netzwerkkarte
im Minis Forum
NAS
die Netzwerkkarte, die
hat erst ab, genau,
die ist erst ab Kernel 6.15
dabei. Das heißt, wenn man
Wobei, ich glaube, das stimmt gar nicht.
Ich glaube sogar noch neuer.
Sagen wir einfach mal
6.15, ja? Also wenn du jetzt
beispielsweise Debian Stable hast,
mit noch einem älteren, dann geht das nicht.
Aber ansonsten hast du
recht, es ist
meistens egal, was für
Distribution man verwendet.
Wenn es da Kerneldreiber gibt.
Ich muss mal kurz einen Schnibbel
von meinem Apfel futtern.
Oh ne, ich kann ja nicht rauscopypasten
gescheit. Oh ne.
Moment, habe ich das hier noch? Ah hier, Seite lädt.
Add to Roblox.
Oh, PepeCack added.
Ups
Ah ja, ich sollte vielleicht auch das Richtige drücken
Ja und ich hab mir gedacht, ich mach jetzt einfach
Einfach mal streamen an
Wir schwätzen eineinhalb Stunden
Und dann muss ich wieder auf
By the way, ich bin auch alt.
Es dauert nicht mehr lange, Leute.
Noch ein paar Monate.
Nicht mal so lange.
Dann bin ich 42.
Das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, oder?
Was gibt es zu futtern?
Toastbrot mit Salami drauf.
Ja.
Und ich habe brutales Hunger.
Obwohl ich auf meinem Weg Eis gefuttert habe.
Bei uns gibt es eine Eisdiele.
Die hat gerade Jubiläumsmonat.
Und da kostet das Bällchen Eis nur 1 Euro für den ganzen März.
Da war ich jetzt schon öfters.
Pepo-Fett-Time machen.
Also wann ich genau Geburtstag habe, sage ich nicht.
Aber ein Geburtstagsstream, keine Ahnung.
Man darf nur noch Self-Promotion am Samstag machen.
Hä?
Kannst du maybe DRBD erklären?
Oh, das ist ewig her.
War DRBD nicht dieses Netzwerk-Sync mit irgendwelchen Disks über das Netzwerk gesynkt?
Ich weiß es gar nicht. Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau.
Das ist ewig her, wo ich mal DRBD gemacht habe.
Also mit ewig her meine ich mindestens 10 Jahre plus.
DRBD war doch dieses Netzwerk-Sync-Laufwerk.
Distributed Replicated Block Device
Genau
Spiegelung von Blockgeräten
Festplatten zwischen Linux-Servern
Das ist quasi ein Netzwerk
Genau, es fungiert als Netzwerk-Rate 1
Das ist ein Netzwerk-Rate 1
Das trifft es doch eigentlich ganz gut
Aber ich habe das ganz lange schon nicht mehr gesehen
Dass DRBD verwendet wird
Ich weiß aber ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht
Ob es da nicht vielleicht mittlerweile was besseres gibt
Oder so
Für was wollt ihr es denn verwenden?
DRBD
Aber ich kann dir da nicht wirklich großartig was zu erklären
Wie gesagt, ich wusste nur noch
Mit Ach und Krach
Was es überhaupt ist
der thomas krenn schreibt wieder was drüber wobei
aber ich habe das nicht ehrlich also ich kann mich wie gesagt nur wirklich ganz dunkel daran
erinnern wo ich das letzte mal der bd gemacht habe aber das war nicht schwierig
Datenbank werden repliziert
Man hat eine DRBD
Ne, Moment, Moment, Moment
Die Datenbanken werden nicht repliziert
Also, das hat einer mit dem anderen nichts zu tun
DRBD ist quasi eine Netzwerkrate 1
Du kriegst dann ein Blockdevice raus
Da drauf könntest du theoretisch deine Datenbank speichern
Wobei ich mir ehrlich gesagt
Nicht sicher bin, ob es so eine gute Idee ist
eine Datenbank auf ein
DRBD-Device zu machen,
habe ich mir nie Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Ich kann mich nur noch
daran erinnern, dass DRBD selbst nicht so
schwierig war.
DRBD-Config, das war doch
relativ
übersichtlich hier.
Hier, DRBD-Config.
Okay, ich habe nichts
gesagt. Ja doch, ist relativ
übersichtlich.
aber kann ich dir nicht erklären, weil es schon über 10 Jahre her ist, wo ich damit was gemacht habe.
Ja, und also meines Wissens nach ist es ja bei Datenbanken auch so,
dass da der, ich würde sagen, beliebteste Ansatz der Datenbank hochverfügbar zu machen ist,
dass du mehrere Read-Datenbanken hast und eine Master-Write-Datenbank.
Das ist recht beliebt als Ansatz.
Also wie gesagt, Datenbanken und sowas, das ist nicht unbedingt so mein Spezialgebiet.
Aber das sieht man oft.
Dass du so Multiple-Read-Datenbanken hast und nur einer, der halt wirklich schreiben darf.
Und das sich dann repliziert.
Was ganz gut ist, weil die meisten Workloads ja eher Read-Heavy als Write-Heavy sind.
Ja, Pacemaker ist ja nochmal was anderes
War Pacemaker nicht das
Wo
Den anderen
Wo einer der Server abgeschossen wird
Wenn es irgendwie
Split Brain oder sowas gibt
Boah, das ist zu lange her, Alter, wo ich das gemacht hab.
Das wisst, Chat, das wisst ihr wahrscheinlich besser als ich.
So, ich beiß mal kurz in mein Toastbrot rein.
Wir gucken mal kurz was.
Ali Express, Alter.
was zum teufel was was was ist denn der kombi knaller hier alter leute ich habe immerhin
glück man sieht keine nippel also kein kein kein toss aber was zum geil der kombi knaller
was ist das denn gesichtslifting massage what the fuck alter aliexpress also eigentlich wollte ich
gucken wenn man sich hier den minis von home and 5 wie viel das bei aliexpress kostet wow das ist ja richtig teuer
Also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, wie die das rechnen.
Aber 789 minus 70 sind bei mir nicht 509.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das bei euch aussieht.
Willkommensgruß.
Farbe 16G bis 64G.
Moment, ist es random, was ich dann kriege, oder was?
Wird das randomized, wie viel RAM drin ist?
16G RAM und 64G SSD.
Das kann sein.
Aber das sind schon maximal blöde geschrieben, oder?
Naja.
Ich dachte, vielleicht gibt es das besonders günstig.
Gerade bei AliExpress.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ganz im Ernst,
da würde ich wahrscheinlich eher
bei denen direkt bestellen.
Also ich muss ja nichts bestellen.
Ich hab das Ding ja schon da.
Übrigens, Minisforum, die bauen zwar gute...
Also, nee, das muss ich anders sagen.
Nicht gute Hardware.
Die haben eine gute Zusammenstellung, ja?
Das sind gute Pakete.
Das Problem an Minisforum ist,
dass die halt null Support haben in dem Sinn.
Also wer drauf hofft,
dass ein Bug, den es zu Release gibt,
mit einem BIOS-Update behoben wird,
der hat wahrscheinlich gelitten,
weil es wird wahrscheinlich nie einen BIOS-Update geben.
Wo finde ich denn hier die Nassdinger überhaupt?
By Device, Mini-PC, Hauptplatine.
Ähm.
Tablette.
Logisch, die Nasses stehen unter Tablette.
Na klar, was sonst?
Die China-Chinesen, Alter.
Okay, bei AliExpress-Fans 509.
sagt zumindest
a 16 16 GB plus 64 GB SSD
keine Ahnung
die Preist die Preisgebung macht macht für mich keinen Sinn
weil es kostet im Leben doch nicht
das kostet
Ach, meint die?
Ach, jetzt check ich das.
Leute, du musst, glaube ich, über 509 Euro bestellen,
dass du die 70 Euro Rabatt kriegst.
Kann das denn damit gemeint sein?
Ich logg mich jetzt hier gar nicht mal AliExpress ein.
Okay, whatever. Ist auch egal.
Ich will mir eigentlich noch was kaufen.
Ich habe auf Reddit einen Post gesehen,
wo einer einen Laptop hatte mit 64-Gig-SSD.
Und ein Terabyte Cloud wurde als ein Terabyte Laptop beworben.
Ja, die China-Chinesen können da nichts.
Die kennen da nichts.
Die können schon was, aber die kennen da nichts.
Ich meine, die Produktbeschreibungen sind ja auch immer geil.
Wenn du bei Amazon guckst, gibt es eigentlich noch diese Cogeek-Steckdosenleiste.
Diese Namen von diesen China-Dingern immer.
Die Titel von diesen Dingern sind immer krass
Mittlerweile blickst du bei AliExpress
Nicht mehr durch, was da geht
Ich glaube, die sind
Mittlerweile über
irgendwas in den alibaba cloud service wird da translated können schwetten
Puzzle Meister, danke für den Sub.
Ich habe da ewig nichts mehr bestellt.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum AliExpress in der Meinung ist,
Irgendwelche Silikon Mund Dinger will ich da jetzt haben
Keine Ahnung
Hoch was das was passiert hier
M.T.
Okay.
Ja gut.
Mit Microsoft 365 1,1
Terabyte Speicher.
Zumindest kann man das erkennen.
was damit gemeint ist.
Ne.
Hatte ich noch nie probiert.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube,
dieses Minis-Forum, Minis-Cloud-OS
ist richtiger Schrott.
So mein Eindruck von dem, was ich gelesen habe.
Das habe ich noch nicht mal gebootet.
Ich habe als allererstes
direkt...
Okay, nee, das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe...
das auf
ich hab
Clonezilla gestartet
und mir das
gebackupt, falls ich es doch nochmal brauche
irgendwann.
Und dann hab ich es direkt runtergeschmissen.
Und wie gesagt,
ich glaube, das ist
Massive-Schrott. Warum hab ich eigentlich
einen CPU-Kern, der 100% ausgelastet ist?
Kann mir das jemand
erklären?
firefox alles bestimmt leute es bestimmt aliexpress der mind bei mir im hintergrund
ja klar was sonst aliexpress einfach 100 prozent cpu last
So, Chad
Gibt es sonst irgendwas Spannendes?
Was ist denn?
Bolt D?
Thunderbolt Device Management
Aha
Darfst du fragen? Bin ich nicht.
Fragen?
Dürft ihr prinzipiell alles im Chat?
Ob ich beantworte oder was anderes?
Der Bauer hat im letzten Video darüber berichtet,
dass er Kupfer bestellt hat für 40.000 Euro,
aber es wascht.
Was? Ey, vom...
Ich hab schon ewig
kein Video mehr vom
der Achtauer geguckt.
Ich wurde betrogen
40.000 Euro
Betrug
Hat er in China bestellt oder
War das China Genesens Camp
Ich kann
Aber ganz im Ernst
Also ich persönlich hatte bisher
Nur gute Erfahrungen mit AliExpress
Die haben, also ich hatte
Einen
Fall, wo sie,
wo es zumindest den Anschein hatte, als
wollen sie mich scammen. Ja?
Ich weiß, ich weiß auch gar nicht mehr, was ich bestellt
hab. Zumindest haben die mir eine
Versandbestätigung geschickt und ein
Tracking, Tracking-Nummer.
Und
das stand dann permanent
wochenlang auf
irgendwie, wird zum,
wird zum Flughafen transportiert, wird zum
Flughafen transportiert, wird zum Flughafen transportiert.
So, und irgendwann hab ich dann mal einen Kunden, wie heißt das, so einen Case aufgemacht bei AliExpress
Hab gesagt, ey, keine Ahnung, was die da treiben, da kommt nix, da tut sich nix
Und dann hat AliExpress die angeschrieben
Die haben sich nochmal bei mir gemeldet von dem Versand
Oder von dem Shop, wo ich bestellt hab
Und haben gesagt, ah, jetzt haben wir es aber wirklich verschickt
Haben mir nochmal die gleiche Sendeverfolgungsnummer gegeben
War natürlich wieder nix
und dann hat AliExpress mir geschrieben, ja bitte antworten Sie hier drauf,
ob der Fall zu Ihrer Zufriedenheit gelöst wurde.
Und ich habe dann einfach nur den Abend nicht mehr drauf geantwortet
und am nächsten Morgen hat AliExpress von sich aus schon geschrieben,
ah wir sehen, es ist nicht erfolgreich gewesen, hier haben Sie Ihr Geld wieder.
Also die haben weniger Stress und weniger Geschiss gemacht bei AliExpress
als PayPal Käuferschutz oder sowas.
es hat einfach funktioniert also ich kann da echt nichts negative sagen über china chinesen
bestellen lqrs danke schön für den sub exzellente subscription wo man das video von bauer gucken das
interessiert mich was wie sie ihn da gestimmt haben zeigt mal her hallo zusammen willkommen
Willkommen zurück zu einem weiteren Video.
Heute leider mal ein nicht so schönes Video.
Ist die Lautstärke okay?
Für mich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich unangenehm.
Ja, ich glaube Lautstärke geht.
Ich habe in den letzten Jahren euch ja bei ganz vielen Sachen mitgenommen.
Von meinem ersten YouTube Studio ins nächste.
Ich wurde bedroht.
Zu tollen Produkten, die ich euch vielleicht vorstellen kann.
Zu natürlich meiner Firma, die ich hier aufbauen konnte.
Auch durch euch.
Und heute habe ich leider mal ein Thema.
Es gibt mal einfach ganz frech die Werbung.
Das hat sich für mich persönlich auch über die Kupfersituation gemacht, was sich da global entwickelt hat.
Deswegen stehe ich auch noch mal hier bei Sieger um diese Platten.
Ich hatte euch da erzählt, dass wir schon im Oktober massive Probleme hatten, Kupfer zu bestellen für unsere Kühlkörperproduktion.
Einfach nicht nur, dass die Preise stark gestiegen sind, sondern dass wir zu dem Zeitpunkt einfach gar nichts mehr kaufen konnten in Europa.
Wir haben ja alles Mögliche abgegrast, alle möglichen Lieferanten, die wir kennen und haben am Ende nichts mehr bekommen.
Und dann dachte ich, ey, ein Ausweg könnte sein, wir probieren das mal in Asien, also in China.
Und wir wechseln kurz ins YouTube-Studio, hier kann ich es euch entspannter erzählen.
Also, ich sagte, okay, ich schreibe einfach mal ein paar Lieferanten in China an und hole mir Angebote ein.
Erstmal, um auch zu sehen, ob die dort die ganzen...
Das ist eigentlich schon krass, dass du keinen Kupfer mehr kaufen kannst, einfach so, ne?
... gleichen Probleme haben wie wir hier, was erstmal die Liefersituation und auch die Preise betrifft.
Und wir wollten insgesamt ungefähr...
das teilweise echt heftig ist.
Es werden ja teilweise hier
meterlang Kabel geklaut,
um daraus das Kupfer quasi zu
schucken. Oder
letztens, gar nicht so weit
weg hier, wurden Bahnkleise
geklaut. Stellt euch das mal vor,
die sind da einfach nachts irgendwie hin,
haben Bahnkleise abmontiert, dann waren die Bahnkleise
weg.
Haben sie die Bahnkleise
geschuckt.
200 von diesen Kupferplatten kaufen.
Da hatte ich im letzten Video schon gesagt, die haben
wir hier drauf, für ungefähr 190 Euro das Stück
damals. Also bei 200 Platten kann man...
Doch, und es kommt nicht nur bei uns vor.
Muss man News suchen. Bahnkleise werden öfters
geklaut in letzter Zeit.
Ausrechnen, das sind knapp
40.000 Euro an
Materialwert. Und da war mir schon klar,
ey, ich werde das auf gar keinen
Fall bei einem einzigen Lieferanten
bestellen, die wir ja alle nicht kennen.
Wir haben noch nie mit einem von diesen Lieferanten zusammengearbeitet.
Da war mir das Risiko
zu hoch, weshalb ich direkt von vornherein gesagt habe,
ich splitte das auf jeden fall auf auf zwei lieferanten dass wir von einem
100 holen und von dem anderen auch noch mal das klingt ich habe dann zwei
gefunden und die sagen auch gut durchdacht also ich habe das ja also man
merkt schon dass er das weiß was er macht ich werde komplett los der jahre
schon ganz oft gemacht gerade über alibaba man findet da gerade für den
industriebereich wirklich sehr sehr gute lieferanten auch sehr sehr zuverlässige
lieferanten da haben wir über die jahre wirklich sehr gute erfahrungen gemacht
und dann habe ich zwei gefunden der eine ist da seit fünf jahren gelistet der
andere seit acht Jahren, die haben über hunderte verifizierte Trades, die über Alibaba dann da gelistet werden.
Das war schon mal so eine Grundvoraussetzung.
Also ich wollte jetzt bei keinem bestellen, der da irgendwie null Sterne hat oder sowas und null Bewertungen,
damit man schon mal so eine Grundsicherheit irgendwo hat.
Ich habe dann auch einen chinesischen Partner bei einem von denen anfragen lassen,
um zu checken, ob das auch erstmal so authentisch aussieht oder nicht.
Und das meinten die, sieht erstmal eigentlich okay aus.
Und bei dem Gesamtvolumen von ungefähr 20.000 Euro pro Bestellung dachte ich mir,
okay, das ist auf jeden Fall was, was wir nicht vorkasse bezahlen wollen.
Dafür ist es einfach irgendwie zu unsicher.
Gleichermaßen ist es für den Lieferanten ja das gleiche Thema.
Wir schreiben denen von der anderen Seite des Globus und für die ist ja das gleiche Thema.
Wenn die jetzt einfach Rohmaterial lossenden und es ist nicht bezahlt,
haben die natürlich auch ein enormes Risiko.
Das heißt, wir haben uns auf 30, 70 geeinigt, das heißt 30% Anzahlung
und 70% sollten geleistet werden, wenn das Zeug auf dem Schiff unterwegs ist
und jemand uns bestätigt, dass die Ware tatsächlich unterwegs ist.
So ist es dann seinen Weg gegangen, alles hat soweit erstmal gepasst, die Kommunikation war immer super, da kann ich echt gar nichts sagen und ich habe mir auch immer zwischendurch Bilder vom Zwischenstand aus der Fertigung schicken lassen.
Also zum Beispiel, dass ich hier mir die Ticke von 12mm von der Platte...
Da haben die sich aber, wenn das alles gescampt ist und alles gefakt ist, dann haben die sich aber echt Mühe gegeben.
habe bestätigen lassen oder auch die Länge von den Platten, die Breite von den Platten oder auch,
dass ich mir die Schnittkanten anschauen wollte, einfach nur um zu sehen, wie sind die denn
verarbeitet und hat sich zum Beispiel eine Platte bei der Verarbeitung verbogen oder nicht. Zusätzlich
haben wir dann bei einem von diesen Lieferanten auch noch Aluminium mitbestellt, weil wir bei den
Kühlkörpern hier auch fette Aluminiumplatten brauchen. Also es sind 30 mm starke Platten,
aus denen wir hier dieses Gehäuseteil rausfräsen. Und auch hier das gleiche Spiel. Ich habe mir
zwischendurch über Bilder immer wieder beschädigen lassen, also bei dem Aluminium. Maße haben gepasst
und auch Verarbeitung und alles sah gut aus. Auch die Stückzahl konnte ich über die Bilder
verifizieren und das was ich hier euch gezeigt habe war jetzt nur ein Auszug der Bilder. Also ich habe
noch deutlich mehr als das was ich jetzt hier im Video gezeigt habe. Dann ist einiges an Zeit
vergangen. Irgendwann wurde uns bestätigt, dass die Ware auf dem Schiff ist, also dass alles
verpackt ist. Wir haben eine Tracking-ID bekommen auf welchem Schiff das ist und haben dann die
restlichen 70 Prozent an Zahlungen geleistet. Und dann kam die was? So eine Schifffahrtsroute, die
die dauert in der Regel aktuell um die 40 Tage.
Weil alles andere macht keinen Sinn.
Wir haben zwischendurch überlegt, das per Luftfracht einfliegen zu lassen.
Aber so eine Express-Luftfracht, weil wir reden hier von mehreren Tonnen Material,
da ist man schnell bei 10.000 Euro.
Und dann kann man das ganze Projekt auch sein lassen.
Deswegen Seefracht hier die einzige Option.
Aber dauert einfach sehr, sehr lange.
Und irgendwann war es dann soweit, die Ware war da.
Von dem ersten Lieferanten, in mehreren Kisten gepackt.
Und so im ersten Moment dachte ich mir, ey, das sieht ja gar nicht so schlecht aus.
Dann habe ich erstmal natürlich gecheckt, so ey, passen denn die Maße?
Das ist ja das Erste, was einen interessiert.
Also ist es überhaupt verwendbar?
Das heißt, ich habe dann erstmal gecheckt, ey, haben die genau die Breite, die wir brauchen?
Pass mal auf, am Ende ist es jetzt gar kein Kupfer oder sowas?
Die haben genau 28 Zentimeter Länge, habe ich dann auch gecheckt und war auch genau das, was es sein sollte.
Also Maße erstmal tippitoppi, dann habe ich auch mit einem Winkel geschaut, ob die irgendwie verbogen sind oder so, auch das war super.
Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, das ist ja alles schon mal echt gar nicht so schlecht hier.
Oder nur die obersten Platten Kupfer und darunter irgendwas anderes.
Das ist super schwer.
Und im nächsten Moment, also erstmal, es fällt zwar auf, dass die ein bisschen stark glänzen, aber ey, okay, man weiß ja nie.
Und dann dachte ich mir, gut, wir checken mal die Reinheit davon.
Und dann habe ich einfach mit einem kleinen Seitenschneider einfach hier so an der Ecke so ein kleines bisschen was abgemacht.
Das können wir jetzt nochmal tun hier.
Wirklich ein ganz kleines Stück.
Und das habe ich ins Rastelektronenmikroskop gepackt, um halt die Reinheit zu checken.
Die haben ein Rastelektronenmikroskop.
Ja gut, why not.
Dann ist es halt auch wirklich...
Die bauen ja da auch Dinger, die müssen halt auch mal was ein bisschen genauer gucken.
99,999% Kupfer.
Und das dann alles ins Raster-Elektronen-Mikroskop gepackt und hier sieht man jetzt die zwei kleinen Stücke.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich da schon echt cool finde? Man denkt sich so, ja gut, Kühlkörper und so bauen und so, aber da brauchst du auch schon ganz schön Know-how für. Das ist nicht so hier, wir fräsen uns da mal irgendwie ein paar Kühlkörper oder so.
jeweils von einer Platte weggemacht,
weil ich halt dachte, ey, prüf doch gleich
zwei Platten auf einmal.
Dann auf den Arbeitsabstand rangesubt, ich habe das auch kurz vermessen,
also ihr seht, das ist nur etwas über
einen Millimeter groß, also wirklich klein, aber viel mehr
braucht man nicht. Dann habe ich dir die
Materialanalyse gemacht und er hat
zumindest mal gesagt, hier
100% Kupfer. Das ist
ja schon mal alles gar nicht schlecht.
Nächstes Thema ist dann die Leitfähigkeit,
weil wir wissen erstmal, es ist Kupfer, also
können wir checken wie rein ist das wie ist die wärmeleitfähigkeit das ist ja für uns bei einem
kühler am ende relevant also wir haben ja ein leitfähigkeitsmessgerät und ich habe hier meine
referenzplatte die ich hier noch liegen habe das ist aktuell nicht kalibriert aber ihr seht wir
haben hier 98,4 IACS also 100 prozent was ist alles messgeräte gibt es ja geil bedeutet halt
perfekte Reinheit für Kupfer, perfekte Leitfähigkeit.
Dahin müsste ich das jetzt kalibrieren, aber ihr seht, wir wissen, das ist eine Referenzplatte.
Also wenn wir das 98,5 messen würden, dann würde das passen, dann wüssten wir,
das wäre auf jeden Fall gute Performance.
Dann checken wir mal unser China-Kupfer.
Also man denkt jetzt im ersten Moment, ich messe hier 98, aber ich messe tatsächlich gar nichts,
weil normalerweise muss immer der Piepston kommen, um irgendwas zu messen.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ich das hier auflege, es passiert einfach nichts.
Ich dachte dann in dem Moment so, hm, irgendwie komisch, also ich habe es dann nochmal in die Referenzplatte gehalten,
die wird jedes Mal gemessen, die Platte hier nicht.
Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ist da vielleicht irgendwas, weiß ich nicht,
irgendeine komische Beschichtung drauf oder sowas.
Also habe ich mal gedacht, ey, ich schleife hier ein bisschen was ab, so, ne.
Weiß ja nicht, vielleicht ist da irgendwie ein Korrosionsschutz drauf oder irgendwas.
Dachte dann, okay, packe ich das nochmal drauf.
Misst immer noch nichts.
Ja, ist es doch kein Kupfer?
Man würde ja den Piepston hören, wenn er irgendwas messen würde.
Aber hat nichts gemessen.
Da dachte ich mir, keine Ahnung, fräsen wir doch einfach mal in die Platte rein.
Und die Platte, in die wir...
Ist die hohl oder irgendwas? Kommt jetzt gleich, ey.
...eingefressen haben, ist diese hier.
Oder haben die innen drin Alu und dann nur Außenkupfer?
Hier oben könnt ihr das sehen.
Ah.
Und das ist schon verdächtig.
Ja, das ist, das ist, das hat nur eine Schicht drauf.
Silber.
Und beim Fräsen hat es gefunkt.
Und wenn man Kupfer oder nicht Eisenmetallbearbeitung kennt, dann weiß man, da funkt es nie.
Da gibt es keine Funken, außer man rasselt in eine Schraube rein oder sowas.
Und dann meint ein Kollege, ich glaube, wir müssen mal einen Magneten besorgen.
Diese Kupferplatte ist einfach magnetisch.
Das ist aber mal ein richtig aufwendiger Scam.
Na gut, für 40.000 Euro kann man schon mal aufwendig scammen.
Alle diese Platten sind magnetisch. Und das, weil es eben keine Kupferplatten sind, sondern es sind verkupferte Stahlplatten.
Tja, das sagt...
Jede einzelne, die hier liegt. Und die sind nicht dünn verkupfert, sondern die haben da eine dicke Schicht Kupfer außenrum gemacht.
Sonst hätte es ja am Anfang auch mit der Probe, die ich weggeschnitten habe, hätte der dann auch zum Beispiel Eisen gefunden.
aber er hat nur Kupfer gefunden und nichts anderes. Ich sage euch dieser Moment, ich konnte es nicht
glauben. Also es war auch für mich persönlich echt, ja man kommt sich vor wie ein Trottel,
wirklich man kommt sich vor wie der letzte Idiot, weil man denkt so irgendwie, wie hat man sich so
über den Tisch ziehen lassen, wie konnte das passieren, wo hat man da den Fehler gemacht,
wo war man nicht vorsichtig genug oder wie auch immer das war eine richtige scheiß situation aber
ich dachte er ist ja alles nicht so also ist schon scheiße ja wenn wir über 20.000 euro reden aber
noch den anderen lieferanten dann gleich das gleiche scammler an unter der haube für andere
laden ja gut sind halt 20.000 euro den anderen lieferanten und das hier ist der andere lieferant
bei dem anderen lieferant also der zweite da haben wir auch noch alu mitbestellt und wir sehen hier
zumindest mal, wir sehen einen großen Stapel von Aluminiumplatten.
Und ja, hier ist es mal nichts magnetisch.
Das ist Aluminium.
Aluminium haben wir gecheckt.
Das ist 100% Aluminium.
Zweite Box Alu, weil wir haben halt viele von diesen Platten bestellt.
Das sind übrigens diese fetten Teile, von denen ich gesprochen habe.
Also wirklich groß, schwer.
Also wie gesagt, 30 mm dicke Aluplatten,
Aluplatten, aus denen wir die Grafikkartengehäuse rausfräsen.
Und ja, dann dachte ich so, okay, das ist ja schon mal nicht so schlecht.
Also ich muss auch dazu sagen, zu dem Tag war ich nicht selber im Office.
Ich habe das dann von Kollegen machen lassen.
Und gucken wir mal in die Box rein hier.
Ein Kollege hat dann hier aufgemacht und da sehen wir Aluplatten, Aluplatten.
es ist genau das was ihr denkt da sind stahlplatten und hier unten ist gar nichts
so kann man das noch mal ein bisschen besser sehen also dass moment da fehlt einfach die
hälfte oder was ist mit den alu platten gefüllt wie wir es haben wollten und hier unten sagt man
so die unteren 60 prozent haben sie sich gedacht machen ein bisschen stahl rein damit vom gewicht
her am ende halb das ja die luxe gern und das unten was wir dann wohl weil stahl ist ja schwerer
dementsprechend kann unten holt sein jetzt natürlich auch die frage was ist mit dem kupfer
vom zweiten lieferanten wir haben ja auch kupfer aufgeteilt und das ist hier eine von den zwei
boxen also erstmal muss man sagen natürlich super professionell da reingestapelt da denkt man schon
so das kann ja eigentlich nichts werden
hier sehen könnt nicht magnetisch das ist ja schon mal richtig gut oder oder
was auf das ist das ist gar kein kupfer jetzt immerhin funktioniert das
leitfähigkeitsmesser gerät aber wenn man hier nach sich an
Das macht 85 Prozent. Also das ist Kupfer mit absolut beschissener Reinheit.
Und das ist nicht das einzige Problem. Wäre das das, dann würde ich sagen, okay, ey Kupfer,
wir kriegen ja einen guten Schrottpreis. Dann verzichtet man auf die 10, 20 Prozent und dann
ist es ebenso das problem ist wenn wir auch hier einfach mal so die obersten
also das ist kupfer das ist auf jeden fall auch gut war also wenn es unten
drunter irgendwas anderes haben wir plötzlich sachen die einfach komplett
anders aussehen und wie ihr seht halte die scammer haben sich wirklich mühe
gegeben haben wir hier wieder schön magnetische teile wirklich die tatsache dass es zweimal
passiert ist bestimmt gleicher laden dahinter andere aliexpress shop jetzt noch die worte und
ich konnte es jetzt schon ein paar wochen verdauen und es ist immer noch richtig richtig schlimm also
Also es ist für uns auch finanziell natürlich Katastrophe.
Also das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Wir haben jetzt hier fast 40.000 Euro verbrannt.
Das Zeug ist halt nichts wert.
Also vielleicht kriegt man halt ein paar Tausend Euro wieder.
Also die Aluplatten müssen wir mal gucken.
Da lassen wir gerade prüfen, was das für eine Legierung genau ist
oder ob die uns da auch abgezogen haben.
Weil wir brauchen natürlich eine spezifische Legierung.
Und wenn es irgendwas anderes ist, dann bringt uns das nichts.
da müssen wir mal schauen
es sind ein paar Kupferplatten dabei
eine Handvoll, also kriegen wir vielleicht, weiß ich nicht
2.000, 3.000 Euro wieder, aber es ist halt
ne
das sackt schon richtig, also über 35.000 Euro
Schaden, das ist halt wirklich krass und das
Problem für uns ist ja natürlich auch
Produktionsplanung
wir haben ja dadurch auch einen Produktionsausfall
Sie haben nicht nur Geld zum Fenster rausgeschmissen
Sie können jetzt ja auch nichts
weiter bauen und verkaufen
die wir machen wollten, wo wir
auf das rohmaterial gewartet haben und natürlich ist das wenn man das on top rechnet ja ein
unfassbar großer finanzieller schaden und das ist echt das ist echt ein problem ich sag's
euch ganz ehrlich also ich habe dann auch lange darüber nachgedacht mache ich darüber überhaupt
ein video weil es natürlich mega peinlich und unangenehm ist man fühlt sich wieder trotzdem
ist auch gut wenigstens wenigstens bisschen gibt's doch youtube was soll ich jetzt tun
kann ja nur aus der situation lernen nachher fragt man sich was hätte man besser oder anders
machen können gar nicht erst in china bestellen wäre wahrscheinlich der beste weg gewesen einfach
zu warten hätte uns eine menge ärger und sag mal finanzielle probleme dann dadurch erspart aber es
ist jetzt wie es ist ich habe dann auch gedacht zwischendurch oder was er ist mir nachgedacht
haben das schon für nash lassen wir uns eine kupferplatte zum beispiel per luftfracht per
express senden und überprüfen die bevor wir die große bestellung machen aber wo so viel
kriminelle Energie dahinter ist,
der sendet uns natürlich eine gute
Kupferplatte und das Resultat am Ende ist
genau das gleiche, nur dass wir noch mehr Kosten haben.
Ja,
was soll man da machen?
Die Frage ist jetzt natürlich, was macht man da?
Klar, man schreibt den erstmal
und fragt sie, was die Scheiße soll
und versucht dagegen irgendwie
natürlich auch rechtlich vorzugehen,
aber die Aussicht auf Erfolg ist mit
China halt, ich sag euch ganz ehrlich, gleich null.
Also da könnte ich jetzt wahrscheinlich dann auch wieder
viel Zeit und Geld reinstecken
in Anwälte und was weiß ich.
Die Aussicht, dass man da
irgendwie Recht bekommt, dass man da irgendwie
sein Geld wieder sieht, ist so klein, dass
es wahrscheinlich auch keinen Sinn macht,
das rechtlich zu verfolgen. Das ist das größte
Problem daran. Also ich muss jetzt einfach mal gucken.
Ich halte euch natürlich auf dem Laufenden, wenn
sich da irgendwas entwickelt. Ich glaube es
aber ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Das glaube ich auch nicht, dass sie das Geld
ja je wieder sehen.
...gefallen kann und
wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Da, siehst du?
Tja, was willst du dagegen machen?
So wirklich, so wirklich
hundertprozentig vorbeugen kannst du da ja nicht.
Das Einzige,
ich meine, ohne Scheiß,
selbst wenn da einer hingeflogen wäre
und hätte die Kiste kontrolliert,
wer sagt denn,
dass es die gleiche Kiste wäre,
die sie dann aufs Schiff geladen hätten und sowas.
Also,
ich glaube,
das ist sehr schwierig, da irgendwas
gegen zu machen.
Moment.
Ah.
Selbst abholen und mit dem LKW
zurückfahren, oder was?
Ah, das hätte ich nicht gedacht,
dass du so heftig gescampt wirst bei China-Chinese.
Ich hatte immer bisher den Eindruck,
dass, wenn was
schiefgelaufen ist, also ich meine,
meine paar Euro, die ich da bei AliExpress bestelle,
kannst du ja nicht vergleichen, ja.
Aber ich meinte nur, also,
ich hatte immer den Eindruck, wenn da was schiefläuft,
oder wenn da was nicht klappt, dann
weil da irgendwie einer zu planlos war,
und was schiefgelaufen ist, und nicht weil da einer absichtlich
scammen wollte, aber die wollten ja offensichtlich
absichtlich scammen,
und auch
mit richtig viel Aufwand.
Naja.
schon nicht ohne
das war Premium
Deluxe Scam
mal kurz gucken
ob wir irgendwie
updaten
aha, IntelliJ
checkt Updates
IntelliJ wird geupdatet
ich mach mal kurz wieder Musik an
ja, Kleinanzeigen
hat sie klingt also mittlerweile heißt es ja nicht mehr ebay kleinanzeigen aber
das muss so ziemlich die beschissenste plattform aller zeiten seine also ich
lese ja immer nur was letzte preis auf reddit und da ist gefühlt ja alles gern
mittlerweile im moment die china chinesen sind doch zu gar nicht zum
unerheblichen teil an blizzard beteiligt mittlerweile ist es nicht so dass gar
nicht so kleiner teil mittlerweile tencent gehört leon eigentlich für den
ab wollen wir mal zusammen auf die kleinerzeiten scams lesen kann machen aber nicht heute
die
monka es aller gibt wirklich noch leute die was mit soap machen so ist das
Jason
der 2000er Jahre.
Könnte man das so sagen?
Also das, was man damals
über Apis ausgetauscht hat, anstatt
Jason war Soap.
Soap ist so ein komisches XML.
DCF.
Damit habe ich nie was gemacht.
Ich weiß nur noch, dass es Windows
Communication Foundation heißt
Richtig?
Also damit habe ich nie was gemacht
Das kenne ich nur als
Horror-Stories drumherum
WCF
Nie benutzt
Oder Framework, kann auch sein
Ne, aber ich glaube es heißt Windows Communication Foundation
Oder verwechsel ich das jetzt mit WPF?
Windows Presentation Foundation.
Vielleicht heißt es auch Framework, ja.
Soap ist Schrott, ja.
Also generell ist gefühlt alles XML Schrott.
Gibt es irgendwo auch gescheites XML?
Okay, man könnte jetzt sagen HTML.
HTML ist ja auch gewissermaßen ein bisschen XML.
Ist, ist, das ist eigentlich eine interessante Frage.
Ist HTML eigentlich gültiges XML automatisch?
Weil gültiges XML ist nicht automatisch gültiges HTML, das ist klar.
Max, hast du schon gehört, dass Notepad jetzt auch Bilderunterstützung bekommt,
nachdem das mit dem Markdowns...
Wirklich, Notepad bekommt Bilderunterstützung.
unterstützung nachdem das mit den markt und links ja schon so gut geklappt hat
naja gut microsoft geht dann halt zu ihrer und sagen hier bau in not pet
bla bla bla bilder unterstützung bla sonst was und dann wird das gewalt
coded
Microsoft baut Bildunterstützung in Notepad ein.
Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet, Leute.
Ich kann mir ja nichts besseres vorstellen, dass wir jetzt in Notepad auch noch Bilder einfügen können.
Fehlt nur noch VBA-Support in Notepad, ja.
Ne, ich würde sagen, Excel in Notepad fehlt.
Wenn schon, dann richtig.
Excel.
Was sagen denn die Kommentare? Warum?
Wacht doch
Notepad++
Jetzt wurde gerade hier minus
Notepad++ hatte doch auch letztens ein Problem
War es nicht so, dass
Notepad++ über ihre Update-Server
irgendwelche Meloer verteilt haben.
Weil die gehackermant waren.
Da war doch was.
Das ist noch gar nicht so lange her.
Eins, zwei Monate.
Da war doch hier irgendwelche Geschichten.
Hier haben wir Notepad.
Plus, plus.
Genau.
Ja, hijacked by state.
Sponsored hackers.
Gut, dass ich den Kram nicht installiert habe.
Wozu auch?
Wim Beste, Leute.
Sind wir uns einig, oder?
Reboot.
Naja, ich reboote jetzt nicht.
Ich mach gleich Power Off.
Power Off und Power On
ist ja quasi auch Reboot.
Leute, ich muss mir gerade mal kurz
eine Jacke anziehen.
Halt!
Ich war gerade vorhin im Garten
und dreimal dürft ihr raten,
dreimal dürft ihr raten,
wer im Garten gehockt hat.
Hat im Garten gehockt.
Und als ich hinten im Garten bin,
ist sie gleich auf mich zugeflitzt.
Mau, mau, mau, mau, mau.
So nach dem Motto, ey, gibt's jetzt abends auch noch was zu futtern?
Normalerweise gibt's nur morgens was zu futtern.
Die kommen morgens immer vorbei
und die kriegt dann von mir ein bisschen Trockenfutter rausgestellt.
Das sind nicht meine, ne?
Ist nicht meine. Die besucht mich
seit zwei Wochen oder so.
Regelmäßig.
Und jetzt war die abends da.
Und dann hatte ich das Problem,
dann war ich im Garten
und die hat sich an die Garten,
ans Tor gehockt
und ich musste irgendwie an der Katz
vorbei,
wieder rein, ohne dass sie mit reinkommt.
Das war gar nicht so einfach.
Ich hab dann den Moment abgepasst,
die hat dann gesehen, dass beim Nachbar die Hühner im Hof rumrennen.
Dann ist sie quasi direkt in Jagdmodus gegangen.
Und da bin ich dann ganz schnell durch die Tür und hab die Tür zugemacht.
Ja, die gehört doch auch jemand.
Was heißt noch nicht meine? Es wird auch nicht meine.
Die gehört ja jemand.
Die besucht mich halt ab und zu.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es bei mir Leckerlis gibt.
Die ist schon relativ
Junkermäßig, das sieht man jetzt hier
Vielleicht nicht und hier auch
Nicht so richtig, aber die Katz
Die hat schon ein ordentliches Gewicht
hier.
Apropos Scheiß, den keiner braucht.
Deutsche Telekom
embeds AI Assistant into every...
Moment, was ist das denn jetzt? WTF?
Alter, was ist das für eine Seite?
Deny all.
Was ist das für eine Seite?
Das ist ja grausam.
Die Telekom
baut AI in jeden Call... Eleven Labs.
Eleven Labs, das sind doch die mit
diesem...
äh, mit Stimmenisolierung
und sowas.
So Stimmenklonen
Also ich will's jetzt nicht lesen,
aber die gehen mir
alle echt auf den Sack.
das ist halt wieder das Problem,
dass jetzt überall,
weil die gehen ja alle miteinander Tennis und Golf spielen
und sonst was, die ganzen CEOs,
und die haben sich jetzt alle
auf KI eingeschossen.
Und da will, glaube ich,
beim nächsten Mal Tennis spielen,
jeder dem anderen erzählen,
wie geil sie jetzt mit KI sind.
Und dann wird halt KI,
jedem noch so sinnlosen Ding
wird irgendwas mit KI gemacht.
ruf jetzt mal Microsoft an.
Der Chef von Microsoft hatte doch
vor noch nicht allzu langer Zeit, ging noch da sowas rum,
dass er eine Mail an seine Mitarbeiter
geschrieben hat, wer keinen Bock
auf AI hat, kann sich quasi gleich
verpissen.
Und der will halt auch nichts anderes
hören und deswegen kommt dann
halt auch so ein Shit wie KI
in Notepad, weil sich
keiner dem traut, seinem
Chef zu sagen,
macht keinen Sinn.
Also die wollen ja eigentlich dann, das ist halt das Problem, wenn du nur eine Sache hören willst, überlegt euch mal, ihr wollt in so einem Unternehmen Karriere machen, ihr seid so richtig der Karrierekreinder, würdet ihr dann ernsthaft sagen, also wenn ihr wisst, der Chef und der Chef deines Chefs und die wollen alle auf Teufel komm raus KI oder quasi nur noch hören, wollen nur noch was hören, wenn da auch KI dabei ist, würdest du dann ernsthaft sagen,
Ja, eigentlich macht es keinen Sinn, KI in einem einfachen Notepad Texteditor mitgedürft.
Nee, dann sagst du natürlich, Leute, wir machen Notepad zu KI First Texteditor.
Und dann sind die happy und gehypt.
Hast du die DLSS 5 mitbekommen?
Ja, die habe ich mitbekommen.
Was ich nicht so genau checke ist,
Ich dachte eigentlich bisher
Dass, genau
Dass DLSS sowas wie Anti-Aliasing
Sagen wir mal ist, ja
Für Kantenklettung und sowas
Was ich nicht so ganz checke ist
Warum DLSS auf einmal
Irgendwelche Gesichter
K.I.T.
Das habe ich nicht gecheckt
Und dann bin ich zu dem Schluss gekommen,
dass das mal wieder einfach
KI irgendwo draufgepappt ist,
obwohl man es nicht braucht.
Oder noch mehr KI.
Es war ja vorher schon KI.
Jetzt haben wir bald
auch noch in Spielen irgendwelche komischen...
Das sieht so...
Das sieht so... Ich weiß nicht.
Das sieht so out of...
Das ist überhaupt nicht richtig greifbar, aber ich finde es sieht nicht organisch passend aus.
Es sieht aus, wie schlecht drüber gefotoshopt.
An Kenny Valley, ja, genau, ja, ja, genau, genau.
Ich sag euch ganz ehrlich,
mir ist das linke
lieber als das rechte.
Sieht furchtbar aus.
Okay, stimmen wir mal mit ab.
Guck mal.
Machen sie das nicht schon die ganze...
Okay, außer es ist ein Bioware-Spiel.
Daran kann man sich vielleicht drüber streiten.
Die Wettermeldung war KI-generiert im Radio.
No.
AI-Slob ist überall, Leute.
Ah, ich finde das asskig.
Ups, ich finde das Ascii-Aquarium immer so entspannend.
Könnt mir den ganzen Tag einfach nur Ascii-Aquarium angucken.
Vielleicht ein Ticken schneller so.
So, so ist das optimal, das Ascii-Aquarium.
Ja, und das kommt auch noch dazu, da habt ihr ganz recht, Chat.
Das ist letztendlich...
Zerstörung von Art Direction.
Ja.
Wo ich eh bei manchen Games
irgendwie das Gefühl hab, so richtig
merke ich es da teilweise nicht mehr,
dass sich da einer Gedanken drüber
gemacht hat, dass das ein gewisser
so
Design dahinter steht,
gewisse Philosophie dahinter steht
und das zueinander passen muss.
Gibt aber auch andere Beispiele. Also was ich
richtig gut fand ist,
Wo ja viele Leute gesagt haben, irgendwie auch
AI-Slob, AI-Slob. Ich weiß nicht, wie die
darauf kommen. Expedition
33 fand ich richtig
gut.
Von, ähm,
der, wie soll man sagen,
wie das alles harmoniert hat, ja.
Auch richtig schöne Landschaft
und sowas. Da hast du gemerkt,
okay, da hat sich einer Gedanken drum gemacht.
Asgequario mit KI.
Was soll die KI hier machen?
Sich neue Fische ausdenken oder sowas?
Leute, ich merke immer, wenn ich nach Frankfurt fahre, ne?
Also erstens stehe ich da ein bisschen früher auf.
Okay, das ist nicht so viel früher.
Alleine wird es nicht sein.
Aber dieses blöde hinfahren, dann auf die Arbeit laufen, dann zurücklaufen, dann zurückfahren, dann heimlaufen und so.
Irgendwie bin ich, obwohl ich weniger an dem Tag geschafft kriege, bin ich kaputter als umgedreht.
Also ich könnte
Theoretisch
Wenn ich jetzt einfach nur
Mal angenommen
Ich würde den ganzen Tag nichts machen
In Frankfurt, wirklich gar nichts
Wäre ich trotzdem geschaffter
Als wie wenn ich einen Tag Homeoffice mache
Wo ich den ganzen Tag von morgens bis abends
Was gemacht habe
Dieses ganze hin und her
Und drum herum
Das ist einfach anstrengend
Deine Bahnrentpost
Bahnrentpost. In letzter Zeit
gab es relativ wenig zu renten.
Ich war ja
recht viel in Frankfurt, ja.
Einmal gab es was zu renten.
Ansonsten war das
eigentlich ganz okay. Wo ich tatsächlich
kurz davor war,
richtig heftig abzurenten,
ist diese ganze Geschichte mit
Streik im Nahverkehr.
Da wollte ich mal eine Runde drüber
abrenten. Aber dann hatte ich
doch keinen Bock mehr.
Also ausgefallen ist erstaunlich wenig in letzter Zeit.
Und die Verspätungen hielten sich auch in Grenzen.
Aber das liegt auch daran, ich feiere mittlerweile zu Zeiten, da ist jetzt nicht mehr so viel los.
Oder noch nicht so viel los.
Mit dem Fiat auf die Arbeitsstelle sind Frankfurt bestimmt auch nicht entspannter.
Kommt auf die Uhrzeit an.
Ein Vorteil ist, wir haben ein eigenes Parkhaus
Ja, Parkhaus ist übertrieben
Tiefgarage
Wobei man da nicht überall parken darf
Es gibt Parkplätze
Die sind immer frei
Und du fragst dich, warum sind die denn immer frei
Und wenn du dich dann mal schlau machst
Stellst du fest, ah
Das sind die festreservierten Parkplätze für den Vorstand
Dass die immer parken können
Doch, ich kann da was dagegen sagen.
Ich finde es kacke, dass die streiken.
Die dürfen das.
Da habe ich auch kein Problem mit, dass die es dürfen.
Aber ich muss es nicht gut finden.
Ich kann mich mal
so gefälligst weiterfahren.
Musst du noch mit der Straßenbahn fahren?
Ähm, mit der U-Bahn
fahre ich eigentlich normalerweise.
Ich fahre, also meistens
fahre ich zum Südbahnhof
und vom Südbahnhof dann
ein paar Stationen noch mit der U-Bahn.
Und ich hab das ja wieder nicht richtig mitgekriegt.
Ich war dann am Südbahnhof und wollte runterlaufen,
aber war zugesperrt.
Und ich hab gesagt, boah, Alter, ihr Spatzen, Alter, wird schon wieder gestreikt.
Da war ich kurz davor, mal drüber abzuranten.
Also fährst du nie mit dem Auto, also ganz, ganz selten.
Ja, das
Angeblich, angeblich ist das in Japan so
Ich hab das jetzt aber nur
Gelesen, aber auch nur
Von Leuten, die das immer wieder gegeben haben
Dass das angeblich so ist
Ob das wirklich so ist, weiß ich nicht
Aber wenn es so wäre
Fände ich das eigentlich
Ein richtig guter Ansatz
Dass man dann einfach
Nicht kontrolliert
Man fährt weiter, kontrolliert nicht
Und quasi
Es ergehen denen einfach Einnahmen
Das fände ich tatsächlich
Ein guter Ansatz
Aber die Japaner sind eh ziemlich
Pfeifert bei vielen Sachen
Manchmal noch nicht so, aber
ja gut das ist natürlich auch ein ganz schönes stück nahm am meisten steht das
auto zumindest schon mal nicht auf der straße da sind die chancen schon mal
geringer dass da irgendwas damit passiert
Oh, Leute, das ist
eine schlechte Idee gewesen.
Ich hänge ja auch vor halb acht vor dem Rechner.
Habe jetzt gefuttert.
Ich merke gerade, ich werde übelst müde.
Wenn ich mich jetzt rüber mal...
Also, ich gehe, keine Ahnung, so eine halbe Stunde oder so,
gehe ich rüber, lege mich ein bisschen aufs Sofa,
gucke noch ein bisschen Fernsehserie oder irgendwas.
Da penne ich bestimmt ein.
Das ist mega abfuck.
Also generell, wenn du in Frankfurt nicht die Möglichkeit hast, irgendwo zu parken,
also, dass du sicher weißt, dass du parken kannst,
dann ist das ziemlich für den Arsch.
Was schaust du im Moment?
Äh, ich gucke gerade Frieren Season 2.
Für alle Anime-Enjoyers.
Mal gucken, ob es wieder Updates gibt in der Zwischenzeit.
Ich meine, wir haben immerhin schon eine Viertelstunde keine Updates gemacht.
Oh, keine Updates.
Ah, okay, immerhin, immerhin JetBrains Toolbox Updates.
Na, weil das wäre ja, das geht ja nicht.
Stellt euch mal vor, mein System ist eine Viertelstunde alt.
soll ich denn da machen da fühle ich mich überhaupt nicht bleeding edge genug
Also alles älter als fünf minuten werde ich nervös
Eigentlich müssten wir jetzt rebooten aber ich reboote nicht power off gleich
max
magst du bücher hörbücher
Ah, ist jetzt nicht so unbedingt meins.
Ich habe natürlich schon ein paar gehört.
Also beispielsweise die Witcher-Kurzgeschichten habe ich als Hörbuch gehört.
Und so ein paar andere Sachen, die mir jetzt gerade nicht einfallen.
Ich habe, wie schon so zig Jahre her, habe ich der Herr der Ringe als Hörbuch.
Ey, das geht ewig.
Wochen konnte man das hören, gefühlt.
also habe ich schon gehört aber ist jetzt nicht so dass ich der große
hörbuch höher wäre
nur
zack guck mal auf youtube noch irgendwas spannendes empfehlen würde
Der N8N-Server wurde exposed.
Ja.
Oh nein.
Please.
Das Technotip.
Okay.
Was ist denn das?
Warum geht dann das Adblocken mal wieder nicht?
Was ist hier los?
Warum ist Adblocken wieder kaputt?
Anzeige.
direkt.
Ey, das hab ich auch schon ein paar Mal gehört,
dass das gut sein soll.
Das fand ich auch gut.
Wie fandest du die Musik von
Expedition 33?
Da bin ich so ein bisschen hin und her
gerissen. Die hatten ein paar
richtig geile Sachen.
Richtig geile Musik.
Aber es war auch zum größten Teil
so
in Richtung
Hintergrund gedudelt.
Also das, was man
zu 90% gehört hat, fand ich
jetzt nicht so geil, aber sie hatten ein paar richtige
Banger dabei.
Ich hab ewig
nix mehr von dem geguckt. Ich hab früher mal ein paar
Videos geguckt, die fand ich gar nicht schlecht.
Ähm.
Aber danach war das ganz
abgedreht. Da hat er irgendwie so ein auf Investment
Zeug oder so gemacht. Da hab ich mir gleich gedacht,
oh geiler, wird das jetzt hier das nächste
kommen in die Gruppe oder was? Und seitdem
habe ich nie wieder geguckt.
Also kann ich gar nichts, kann ich
gar nichts zu sagen.
Aber ist jetzt auch nichts, wo ich
sagen würde, es spricht mich groß an.
Also wenn du das empfehlen kannst,
dann,
das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben.
Ist das nicht,
ist das nicht
so ein Buch eigentlich?
Dungeon Crawler Carl?
Ist das nicht sowas,
wo man selbst Entscheidungen treffen muss
oder sowas?
War das nicht sowas in der Richtung?
Wo du selbst
quasi sagen musst, wie es weiter
geht oder so?
Ich bilde
mir ein, das ist das doch.
Aber das können wir uns
heute nicht angucken. Erstens ist das Video zu lang.
Ist das nicht so?
Doch, oder?
Lit-RPG.
Doch!
Das ist doch sowas.
Genau, da levelst du auf und sowas.
Vielleicht nicht in der Hörbuchvariante.
Das gucken wir uns am Wochenende an.
Dann kann ich mich nämlich wieder drüber lustig machen,
dass er seine, was weiß ich, 15 Kubernetes-Cluster,
drei Proxmox-Cluster
und was weiß ich, was der sonst noch daheim am Start hat.
Fünf DNS-Server, drei Grafanas und was auch immer alles.
Kann ich wieder ein bisschen lustig drüber machen,
dass er im Endeffekt drei oder vier Sachen hostet, die wirklich benutzt.
Der Rest ist Management-Infrastruktur, um Management zu managen von seinen Servern.
Wenn ich das hier unten schon sehe
Proxmox, Trunas, Kubernetes
Guck mal, es ist, es ist, hier
Nichts, oh, oh, okay, okay
Er hostet, er selbst hostet anscheinend
Eine Shortlink
Shortlink, ja immerhin, dafür braucht man
Mindestens immer drei Kubernetes-Cluster
Dass man sich ein paar Shortlinks
Dass man sich ein Shortlink-Service hosten kann, oder?
Also unter drei Kubernetes-Cluster
Die auf
Mindestens
fünf
Proxmox Sachen drunter laufen,
geht's nicht für einen Url-Shortener.
Piehole.
Monitoriert.
Ich sag doch, da ist doch nichts dabei.
Da ist nichts dabei.
Okay, Plex, er guckt ein paar Videos drüber.
Was ist Ersatz-TV?
Was ist das denn?
Gibt's das auf GitHub?
Let's do Transform Your Media Library.
Achso, okay.
Diagramme, N8N,
so. Ja, da ist
wirklich kaum was dabei, was er selbst
also, nur Management
zum Verwalten.
Das gucken wir uns am Samstag an.
Da kann ich ein bisschen drüber ablästern.
Was zahlt
er an Lizenzen?
Ja, von dem Zeug ist doch mehr oder weniger nix,
wo du was lizenzieren musst.
Das ist so ein Setup,
was der Techno-Tim hat.
Wo mir mein Bauchgefühl
sagt
und
wenn es nach Bauchgefühl geht,
wisst ihr ja,
da kenne ich mich aus,
das setup was der hat sagt mein bauchgefühl dass der mehr downtime hat durch seine hoch
verfügbarkeit maßnahmen als wenn er einfach den kram so horsten würde das ist mein bauchgefühl
ja weil das ist dass das geht oftmals bei hoch verfügbarkeit sachen unter dass das ja auch noch
extra komplexität ist und wenn man das nicht richtig macht schafft die hochverfügbarkeit
lösung im endeffekt mehr probleme als ohne dass das geht schon los bei man macht denkt
man denkt sich so ich will hochverfügbarkeit und dementsprechend brauche ich ein raid damit fängt
ja schon an ja das ist schon das erste problem da kommen leute auf die idee und sagen ach komm
machen wir in raid 5 da kann man ein festplatten ausfall abhaben und haben
bisschen auch ein bisschen mehr performance und mehr speicher und alles
ist gut ja die machen dann aber die rechnung ohne den raid rebuild bei
großen platten und die chance habe ich schon 100 mal gesagt die chance dass
in raid 5 das rebuild nicht richtig überlebt bei großen platten oder bei
einer größeren anzahl von platten ist ziemlich hoch
alles for free also alles was ich da jetzt gesehen habe außer vielleicht seine sein
fernsehempfang ist alles kostenlos ja der hat box am start der hat weil sie wasser mit wasser sein
kuba jedes zeug laufen hat aber das kostet ja auch alles nichts das alles andere ist kostenlos
ganz normale open source sachen von github das meiste von github aber das gucken wir uns dann
am Samstag an.
Max, gibt es statt Hochverfügbarkeit nicht
bessere Robustheit?
Da gibt es sogar
Abkürzungen
für.
Die mir aber gerade nicht einfallen.
Return to, ne, wie heißt das?
RB, ne,
return to für diesen kram gibt es abkürzung und das wird sich ganz gern
buzzword mäßig um die ohren gehauen da
Was ist eigentlich aus ESX für ein Raspberry Pi geworden?
Gibt es das noch?
Das gab es mal.
Das weiß ich.
Das ist das.
Das ist das gab.
Aber ich glaube, das haben die nie.
Das haben die nie wieder geupdatet, oder?
Oder doch?
Oder nicht?
Keine Ahnung.
Das fand ich eigentlich ganz cool. Also nicht, dass ich
irgendeinen Anwendungszweck dafür hätte.
Ne.
War so immer...
Ja.
Das meine ich. Das meine ich hier.
Time to recover und sowas.
Ja, ja. Da gibt es so
Buzzword-Sachen für.
Einfach nur sagen, hochverfügbar
an sich sagt ja nichts aus.
Was soll das bedeuten?
Ja.
Ist es schon hochverfügbar, wenn ich einen Loadbalancer davor habe? Ist es hochverfügbar, wenn ich einen Raid 1 habe? Was ist damit genau gemeint? So Sachen wie, es geht kaputt und wie lange dauert es, bis es wieder geht, das finde ich tatsächlich auch sinnvollere Metriken, als einfach nur zu sagen, es ist hochverfügbar.
Cube wird
Cube wird, habe ich noch nie benutzt
Ich finde das vom Ansatz her
Aber auch irgendwie nicht so geil
Und wisst ihr was ich auch nicht so geil finde
Cube CTL
Da gibt es Leute
und haben umgedreht.
Wie sprecht ihr Cube CTL aus?
Falls ihr das benutzt
und auch ab und zu mal ausspricht.
Aussprecht.
Genauso wie du.
Cube Karte.
Leute, hört mir auf.
Nicht wirklich.
Ihr wollt mich jetzt triggern, oder?
Ihr sagt nicht wirklich Cube Karte.
Ich finde diese Aussprache
so schrecklich.
Ich kenn auch ein paar, die das
sagen. Da muss ich immer... Das ist wirklich
Dice of Cringe jedes Mal.
Wenn ich das hör. Cube Cuttle,
Alter. Ah!
Ihr seid auch so welche. Okay.
Na gut
Vielleicht bin ich ja auch in der Minderheit
Und es sprechen mehr Leute
Cube Cuttle aus
Cute Cuttle
Ich sag Cube CTL
Ja, das ist ja mal schlimm,
der Cube-Kartel.
Oh, Chat, ich muss mal kurz
in meinen Kalender gucken,
wie viel gemietet wird morgen.
Lass mich das mal checken gleich.
wenn morgen nur den ganzen tag gemietet wird dann fahre ich wieder nach frankfurt weil ob
ich da vom rechner sitzt oder daheim ist kein problem da kann ich auch bei zeiten heimfahren
und miete einfach im zug weiter mit dem headset ok also geht los nur zu eigentlich noch cmd unter
windows nie mehr ganz normales terminal also diese neue terminal neue terminal app
Besser als Leute, die zu SCRG
Strick sagen
Das ist auch schlimm
Das sieht man aber selten
Also lass mal kurz gucken
Was wird
Was wird morgen gemietet
Es geht los, okay
Es geht erst um 9.30 Uhr los, Leute
Mit Gemiete
Daily Scrum
Excellent
Also, äh, Projekt Daily Scrum.
Dann geht's weiter, ähm, Team Daily.
Danach gibt's irgendwas Monitoring Grafana, wo ich ehrlich gesagt gerade gar keine Ahnung hab, was das eigentlich ist, aber na gut.
Danach gibt es ein Service Meeting.
Dann gibt es, oh, mein Lieblings, Projekt SureFix, Leute.
Projekt SureFix.
Wie viele Surefixes habt ihr so in der Woche?
Surefix, das ist auch so ein Ding, das hat die letzten paar Jahre zugenommen.
Gefühlt macht jeder zu allem mittlerweile Surefixes.
Schrutscher CHU, ja ey, manche Aussprache verstehe ich auch nicht.
Und dann habe ich noch mittags was
Das heißt
Ich weiß was das für ein Termin ist
Ich habe einen Termin mittags um 12.45 Uhr
Das heißt
Linux Admin Sachen
Keck B
Da weiß ich sogar, wofür es ist.
Wenn das jemand in meinem Kalender liest,
der hat auch absolut keine Ahnung.
12.45 Uhr.
Das ist 12.45 Uhr,
weil wir dann aus der Kantine wieder da sind.
Das ist ein Termin mit unserem Azubi.
Den hab ich eingestellt.
Und da heißt Linux-Admin-Sachen keck weh.
Ja, okay.
Also wird morgen eigentlich fast wieder den ganzen Tag gemietet.
Das heißt, ich fahr morgen nach Frankfurt.
Und miete da halt den ganzen Tag.
über Ostern komplette Umstellung auf
SAP
Das ist doch SAP, oder?
S4 HANA
Ich kenn das nur vom Namen her und alle
alle, die damit was zu tun haben
wollen lieber nix damit zu tun haben
Dachte, du hast einen Termin
zum Futtern um 12.45 Uhr
Ne, da bin ich schon fertig futtern
Mein Azubi lernt erstmal Linux Basics
Bevor er Big Cloud Kubernetes
Cube Cuttle Action macht
Kann der Azubi in Twitch Emotes sprechen?
Ne, der ist irgendwie nicht so
Hab ich zumindest den Eindruck
Nicht so
YouTube, Twitch und Streaming affin
Was ich eigentlich merkwürdig finde
weil der ist glaube ich
wie alt ist der?
22 oder so?
oder 20 oder irgendwie sowas
also eigentlich ist er in einem Alter wo man sehr
Youtube und Streaming affin sein müsste
aber ist er glaube ich gar nicht so
ich hatte noch nicht einmal
TikTok scrollen sehen auf dem Handy
vielleicht gibt er sich auch Mühe
dass man ihn nicht TikTok-Scrollen sieht.
Keine Ahnung.
Wie sieht gerade die Jobsituation
in Frankfurt aus?
Wird immer noch viel IT gesucht?
Also ich kann da nur für uns sprechen.
Bei uns in der Versicherung.
Wir suchen weniger Leute
als noch vor ein paar Jahren.
Aber wir suchen immer noch.
Und wir suchen auch tatsächlich Junior-Leute.
Es wurde erst letztens
ein Junior-Storage-Admin gesucht.
Wenn wir uns mal Compose anschauen, da gibt es gar nicht so viel.
Haben wir doch sogar schon mal gemacht.
Das Schöne bei Compose ist, dass es bei Kubernetes mit dabei ist.
In Cube-Karte.
Boah, ich darf mir das nicht angewöhnen.
Ich cringe da innerlich, wenn ich das schon ausspreche.
richtig quetsch
ich muss jetzt gleich auf neue fünf minuten noch
dann gehe ich zähneputzen legt mich von fernseh gucken bis in serie und dann
Geh ich pennen.
Übelst kaputt schon.
Also, was mir da jetzt einfällt,
also das, was ich bei uns von SAP
immer mitkriege, ist,
dass die Leute, die mit SAP
was zu tun haben, aber die keine
SAP, wie nennt man das so,
so Experten sind,
dass die immer froh sind, wenn sie dann
nichts mehr mit SAP zu tun haben.
Die einzigen, die
die voll geil auf SAP sind,
sind so die SAP-
Consultant-Leute.
Die sind da ganz scharf drauf. Wobei ich mich
bei denen auch frage, ob die
wirklich so scharf drauf sind oder halt
einfach nur Fettkohle damit machen.
Wahrscheinlich sind die scharf drauf, Fettkohle
zu machen und nicht auf SAP selber.
Weil das ist, glaube ich, sowas, wo keiner
so richtig scharf drauf ist.
Die sind alle nur scharf aufs Geld
Du machst ABAP.net und JavaScript
Und
Was gefällt dir am besten
Mein ABAP ist ja diese SAP Sprache
Was gefällt dir davon am besten
20 Jahre alte Programme in ABAP
Mit Business Logik ist Pain
Das kann ich mir vorstellen
.NET
Also bei mir wäre es glaube ich auch
hier die zwei Sachen
eindeutig vorne
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, mittlerweile
bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher
was ich
lieber mache. Ich finde
JavaScript ist eine echt nice Programmiersprache
geworden mittlerweile und
C Sharp ist ja so mein all time
favorite
aber trotzdem, mir macht es auch
Bock Frontend Sachen zu machen mittlerweile
Oh.
Also ich hab von SAP absolut keine Ahnung.
Ich krieg das immer nur mit,
wenn mal irgendwie Verbindung wieder zu SAP
gestört ist und dann geht ihnen ein Ticket bei uns auf
oder so.
Aber ansonsten
Was für Themen bringst du deinem Azubi bei?
Wir machen gerade Set-Servers zusammen.
Einmal die Woche.
Besser gesagt, er macht
und darf mir dann erklären, was er gemacht hat.
das neue Meme-Bot.
Ich brauche kein neues.
Guck, guck, guck.
Ich brauche kein neues, weil
das geht ja noch.
Ich habe das jetzt ja auf dem zweiten Desktop
und
da geht das Overlay ja noch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es die Wochen auf die Reihe kriege.
Am Wochenende.
Am Wochenende können wir das machen.
Aber unter einer Woche bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher.
Ob das eine gute Sache ist.
Ob ich das hinkriege.
Aber outdated.
Das stimmt.
Das ist heftig outdated.
Das basiert auf .NET 4.8.
.NET Framework 4.8.
Javascript beliebter geworden wegen AI?
Ich würde sagen, Javascript war schon vor AI mit die beliebteste Programmiersprache.
Also, wenn man mal beliebt gleichsetzt mit, wird viel verwendet.
Aber ich finde Javascript auch an sich eine wirklich angenehme Programmiersprache mittlerweile.
Javascript zeigt, wie man es gut machen kann.
Ja, also von einer Sprache, die früher echt nicht so geil war, zu einer wirklich gut zu benutzenden, in sich schlüssigen Sprache, wenn man mal von diesen Legacy-Wirren, die es halt immer noch hat und die es auch immer haben wird, absieht.
Ja, aber die neuen Sachen, die sie da gebaut haben, sie haben sich halt gute Sachen zusammengeklaut.
Ja, sie haben sich beispielsweise Async Await komplett von .NET gerippt.
Das ist 1 zu 1, ja.
Also auch von der Syntax her, ist 1 zu 1.
Und wenn man sich mal so die letzten Features durchguckt, sieht man mal, die haben das wirklich gut durchdacht.
Das JavaScript-Gremium.
Oder wie die auch genau heißen.
Im Gegensatz zum C++-Gremium.
Das macht alles nur immer noch schlimmer.
Gib deinem Azubi das als Aufgabe.
Nee, das geht nicht. Das könnte er bei uns gar nicht machen.
Da kann er gar kein .NET Windows Zeug ausführen, wenn es nicht signiert ist.
Auf normalen Rechnern.
Da müsste er sich irgendeine Art Windows Admin Kiste bestellen.
Ich bin der Meinung, das trifft bei Programmiersprachen tatsächlich zu.
Weil es gibt so viele Sprachen, die manche Konzepte einfach richtig gut umgesetzt haben.
Warum sich nicht irgendwo bedienen, wo man schon weiß, das hat sich als gut etabliert, ja?
Hast du ein JavaScript-Frontend-Framework, das du bevorzugt wie...
Äh, Svelte.
Finde ich richtig pock.
Ich weiß nicht, wie...
Praktikabel,
das im Business Enterprise Umfeld ist,
keine Ahnung, aber nachdem ich kein Frontend-Entwickler bin
und im Business Enterprise Umfeld
irgendwas Frontend-mäßiges machen muss,
kann ich einfach das verwenden, was mir am besten gefällt.
Im Business Enterprise Umfeld
wäre es höchstwahrscheinlich React oder Angular.
Da hast du recht.
Ja, man kann die Regel nehmen, guck dir an, was C++ macht und mach was anderes.
Da hast du zumindest schon mal eine Sache, die kacke ist, ausgeklammert.
Es stimmt.
Ja, wenn du... Das ist ein echter Witz.
C++ kann bei fast allen Sachen für ein Negativbeispiel herhalten.
suchst du ein Negativbeispiel
für, boah, keine Ahnung
wie kann man
eklige Lambda-Functions machen?
C++
wie kann man ekliges DateTime machen?
wie kann man eklige Generings machen? C++
du kannst bei fast allem
kannst du defaultmäßig sagen
ah, gibt es irgendeine Programmiersprache, die das schlecht gemacht hat?
ah, C++
header files
ich fange mal gar nicht mal von an
der Standard
Standard Backinserter
ja ich weiß nicht was
die sich da immer reinhauen bevor die
C++ Standardsachen schreiben
keine Ahnung
vielleicht ist es auch umgedreht das Problem
Die sind auf Entzug oder so und hauen sich nix rein vorher.
Man müsste mal so einen Test machen, Leute.
So einen Test.
Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel
designt ein C++
26 Feature
versus das C++ Gremium
designt ein C++ 26
Feature. Mal gucken,
was davon am Ende besser ist.
Also ich tippe auf Frankfurt Bahnhofsviertel
designt C++ Feature.
Okay, Leute.
Jetzt muss ich aber
auf.
War heute ein Stream
außerhalb
der Reihe.
Aber ich dachte mir,
ein Stream ist besser als kein Stream.
Deswegen, wir sehen uns spätestens
Freitag oder Samstag.
Vielleicht auch schon mal vorher.
Bis dann.
Macht's gut, Leute.
See you.
Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020